Disney's latest Tron game called Tron  Runner is coming to Xbox one and  PlayStation 4 the game was announced for  PC during the game awards back in  December and it will launch across all  three platforms on februari 16th for  twenty dollars however if you can't wait  that long and have a PC the game is  currently an early access on steam for  ten bucks in Tron runner you can create  an avatar and customize it with dozens  of elements including light cycles suits  and helmets in all the game boasts more  than 30 levels to zip through while a  stream mode challenges players to make  their way through harrowing remixes of  existing levels Disney's product  development director chris nichols said  in a statement that the company's  overarching goal was to make a game that  quote remained authentic to tron's  arcade origins and like many arcade  games this Neutron game will support  leaderboards for more gaming and  entertainment news you're already in the  right place